Good afternoon, everyone. Welcome to the session,
Advances in Cancer Research.
I'm Naoko Takebe, oncologist from Stephenson Cancer Center, University of
Oklahoma. And it is my great pleasure to co-chair this session with
Professor Edna Cukerman from Fox Chase Cancer Center.
In order to increase more time for Q&A, we would like to
move to the presentation quickly, but we will have
Q&A after each presentation for about five minutes.
So we appreciate you come to the microphone, and
just your name and affiliation will be appreciated.
For those who are joining online, please
send the questions through the Slido and apps that you have,
so that moderators will pick up your questions.
So, okay. Then I will introduce the first speaker.
Is that okay? Dr. Yize Song. Dr.
Song is from Washington University School of
Medicine in St. Louis, and the title of the presentation
is Asymmetric Emergence of Cardiovascular Disease in
Hematologic Malignancy Survivors. Please welcome Dr. Song.
Hello, everyone. Great honor to be here. Sorry.
Still trying to navigate how to
open the slide stack.
He's
going to do it for you.
Oh, oh. Okay, great. Perfect. Thank you. Thank you. Yeah.
Sorry, I didn't notice that. So today, my talk is about to
dissect the bi-directional relationship between cardiovascular
disease and hematological malignancies.
Let's wait for the slide to show, but before that, maybe I can give my
acknowledgement ahead of time.
I want to thank Dr. James Ingleton.
Before
I started here, he came to me and say he's the sponsor
for my ACR Young Investigator Award,
and he told me a very touching story, which almost made me cry, but I
will cry after this talk. But we are all here
today to fight against cancer and trying to find
a solution for-- oh, sorry, the talk is already there.
So I will start the real talk.
First of all, I have no conflict interest to disclose.
I have never had a conflict of interest.
But
if you are interested, please contact me. I'd love to have one.
So cancers and
cardiovascular disease are the number one and number two cause of death
globally, and they have some shared risk factors like
aging, like obesity, and some genetic
predisposition as well. So there has been study to
show that in solid tumor,
there are increased risk of cardiovascular disease.
But for
hematological malignancy cancer, there's less evidence to show that.
So to solve this gap, we are planning to do a comparative
risk to find out whether
there are increased risk of developing cardiovascular disease
among those hematological malignancy survivors.
Our study population's utilizing those NIH All of Us
research program.
And here are the two cohort I want to introduce you about.
The first cohort is the
hematological malignancy
survivors, where I exclude the CVD
at the time of their cancer diagnosis.
And in the second cohort, there are CVD patients
without the prior hematological malignancy.
So with that, the definition of the two cohort, we will be able
to
identify the follow-up risk of
developing cardiovascular disease in cancer patients, or the risk
of developing
hematological disease in CVD patients.
Looking at the
incidence of
CVD after hematological disease diagnosis,
we were able to see that there's a shocking increase of
CVD incidence, especially during the first two years of a
hematological malignancy cancer diagnosis.
While on the other hand, you can see among those CVD
patients, their risk of developing hematological malignancy
after is at a very slow
progress.
So,
in addition to that, if we compare the time from
hematological malignancy diagnosis to developing CVD, the median
time is 2.4 years. Vice versa, the
median time for
CVD patients to develop hematological malignancy is over four
years.
And to break down by age group, we were able to see the
younger people, their median time to developing CVD
is
much slower than the older people, which also makes sense because aging
is a
factor for both cancer and cardiovascular disease.
And to look at the relative
riskOf between hematologic
survivors and their risk of developing cardiovascular disease, and
among those cardiovascular disease
patients developing cancers. So the
relative risk is pretty high for cancer patients
to developing CVD. And so
striking patients with MDS and multiple myeloma,
they have a very high risk of developing
CVD, especially before the
first five years after their cancer diagnosis.
So we're triggered this, and we were also wondering what type of CVD
disease are
mainly, are more easily to get affected, are
at high risk after you have
the cancer diagnosis.
So arrhythmias is the number one CVD subtypes that are
highly represented after the hematologic
malignancy diagnosis.
Also here on the right-hand side, I compared the
socioeconomic status and their risk of developing CVD
in the hematological malignancy cancer survivors,
where we can see aging is a strong risk
factor. Young people, they have much lower risk, and also female
have a lower risk.
So, so far we have observed this asymmetric trend
between hematologic malignancy and cardiovascular disease.
And we want to know
what's the mechanism here.
So, one of the mechanism hiding is we
suspect those high risk of developing CVD is treatment
induced. So we go through those, all of our data and pull the
treatment record for every patients.
So here, I
classify those patients according to their
prescription and
their treatment types. So we use a composite
score where we utilize their, whether
the instance of a CVD by each treatment group, and
also the median time of developing CVD.
So I was able to see the proteasome inhibitor treatment group,
they have a very high combined score.
So moving forward, I want to study, validate the hypothesis
whether those
highly increased cardiovascular risk
was induced by treatment, especially by the proteasome
inhibitors.
So to conquer the gap,
so we know that cancer patients,
they were excluded from clinical trials
because they have
chronic conditions. So to solve this, we developed this
platform, in vitro platform, to validate the drug-induced
cardiotoxicity called Cell Village,
where we pooled 30 patients, this is still pilot study,
from different ancestry background and from different age and
risk and sex group.
So two treatment arms, one treated with one of the
protein proteasome inhibitor, another one is the control.
And we want to compare before and after treatment, what changed
in those cells.
So,
those are the UMAP of the
single-cell study from the Cell Village.
We can see those donors are well mixed together on the UMAP
side.
But if we look at the transcriptional side, we were able to see that
after treatment, after this proteasome inhibitor treatment,
those cell states of endocytose cell in the heart
changed a lot. So most of the cell, they become
inflammatory or dysfunctional.
And if we compare the cell count, it's also very
obvious that among a lot of cell types, after treatment,
a lot of cells died.
And beyond that, we were able to identify some protective
markers by looking at the DEGs before and after
treatment.
And very luckily, those
DEGs, we also mapped them to the clinical trial
platform and other database to see whether those target are
already targetable. And we were able to see
among those potential protective targets, there are
some of them, they
have already
FDA-approved drugs.
So in summary, there's highly
increased
risk of developing CVD among the hematological malignancy
survivors. And MDS and multiple myeloma, they are at
higher risk.
And on the experimental side, we found
target with FDA-approved drugs, which can be
further validated to
see whether they can have the real cardiovascular
disease protection among the cancer survivors if the
treatment were provided simultaneously.
And with that, I want to thank NIH for hosting the All of
Us Research Program, and also
Pan and Moon Chen from Wash U for the
a lot of co-investigations, and Dr.
Liang from MD Anderson, and Dr. Timsson Rebeck from
Harvard for advising role, and also our co-chair,
Dr. Takebe and Dr.
KokimiAnd also
most importantly, I want to thank all the patients and all the participants.
Every data point matters. And we
get this data because of you, and also the goal
is to use those data to further improve the patients'
outcomes and patient
prognosis driven
new therapies. So thank you all, and also thank you all for
listening. Now I will take questions.
Any questions to Dr. Song?
Okay. Yes. I have a question, Dr. Song.
As an oncologist clinician, I wonder what kind
of definition did you use for survivors?
In other words, the patient finished the treatment and on observation,
or do you have any criteria?
Oh, so the survivors is just the
patients who
live up to date and then continue participating in All of
Us research program. They are not necessarily patients who had treatment.
In fact,
when I pull their treatment information, there's around
20% of patients, they don't have the active record of
having those chemotherapy, those anti-cancer treatment.
So maybe I think for those patients, they are at those, a
walk and wait stage where they are maybe on
remission or maybe other reasons that due to maybe
limited access to healthcare. So they don't have
cancer treatment.
I see. So when you count for the year one, two, three, did you
start from starting the treatment?
Or how did you get, for example, you have the data
for the incidents of the cardiovascular, year one, year two, three.
So when is your start time?
One year after
the beginning of the treatment? Or how did you-- what is your criteria?
So,
I think the benefit of All of Us,
for every record, it has the time. So we have the time
of the patient diagnosis for cardiovascular disease.
We have the time of the treatment. And also,
the first dose and the second dose is all well
documented. Mm-hmm.
Thank you.
So first I want to encourage the
people here to support people who were
selected from abstracts to ask questions.
There's no silly questions, and we're in a very good
vibe room, so everybody's safe. I wanted to
ask you,
the two cohorts were so different in the amount
of individuals per cohort. How did you account,
because you're talking about risk and comparing one cohort of
5,000 to another for 77,000 is a
difficult mathematical thing to do.
So how did you account for those enormous differences?
How do I what?
Account. How do you
compare a 5,000 to a 77,000 cohort?
Yeah.
That is a very good question. So at first, I want to study
those bi-directional
relationship between those two cohort.
But then later I found, even for the CVD cohort, they have
this 10 times small patients. But regarding
the patient who actually developing hematological
malignancy, is a very small proportion of number.
So later on, I pay more attention,
more focus on the first cohort because that's most
significance. Yeah. And the CVD cohort just used as a
reference, with more sample size.
Good work.
Just a question.
I was struck in your late slide about the high
incidence of CVD-
Mm-hmm
... MDS in other patients.
Do you have any evidence to clarify whether it's the use
of particular drugs,
or is it something about the underlying malignant disease that's
interacting with the cardiovascular disease?
Yes.
To answer your question first, different disease, different
hematomalignancy, they have different risk of
developing cardiovascular disease.
And also for the drug, if I can go back to this
slide very quickly. For the drug, we also have different drug.
Their
percentage of developing CVD is different.
So, I pick this proteasome inhibitor because I
study multiple myeloma. That's my focus.
And this proteasome inhibitor is the
drug for multiple myeloma, and also it has very accelerated
speed of developing CVD after that.
So to answer your question, to summarize, we do have
a candidate drug list, and we rank those drug list
to study whether it is true this cardiovascular disease
was induced by anti-cancer treatment.
I'm not sure if I answered your question, but please ask more if you have
additional.
The top of the list is something altogether different in terms of...
Mm-hmm.
Yes. Here I'm not only
including the anti-cancer drugs because there are
other confounding factors, other co-administrated drugs that
can be used on the same patient. So I include them as well.
Okay. So the last question for this session.
Sure.
Great talk. I'm just wondering,
do you see any specific kind of CVD in your patients?
I think you mentioned it's mostly arrhythmias, right?
Yeah.
I'm also wondering, did you get a chance to look into their biochemical
profile? Is there any changes in their blood profile, the patient
who got the CVDs?
Like any electrolyte changes or
just any downstream signaling you see?
That is a great question. I haven't, but that's a
very inspiring comment. I will look into that.
Okay. Thank you.
Thanks.
Great. So first of all, I would like to congratulate your amazing
work in complex patients' data analysis. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Okay, so our next speaker, Dr. Pei
Wan.
Dr. Wan is a professor of genetics and genomic
sciences at Mount Sinai School of Medicine.
Her presentation title is "Decoding Melanoma
Immunogenicity: A Comprehensive Proteogenomic,
Immunopeptidomic, and Metabolomic Atlas."
Thank you.
Thanks for the introduction. It's a great honor of me to have this opportunity
to share a recent multi-omics study of melanoma
on behalf of the NCI CP Tac Melanoma Study Working
Group.
Immune checkpoint inhibitor have really transformed the
treatment of melanoma patient in the past decade and achieved a
substantial clinical benefit. Nevertheless, about 40% to
60% of the patient either does not respond or lose
response over time to ICI treatment.
Our understanding of the underlying mechanisms that limit
therapeutical efficacy remains incomplete.
Our hypothesis is that we need a system-level
multi-omics strategy beyond RNA and
protein in order to bridge that gap.
Towards this goal, we performed a very comprehensive
multi-omics atlas
analysis of melanoma. We collected 13 different
layers of omics data and using those data to detect
novel immune evasion mechanisms and identify
actionable biomarker and novel therapeutical targets.
So in this talk, I will just share a few exciting findings
from this atlas.
Our study cohort consists of 164
cutaneous melanoma patients. Treatment in naive tumor
samples was collected from those patient prospectively.
Among the tumors,
about 46% are primary tumor, and the rest are
metastatic tumors.
And consistent with literature finding, we observed a significant
association with gender male and later tumor stage
with worse survival outcome.
So for majority of the tumors, we are able to collect
13 different multi-omics layer profiles, including
four PTM data, metabolics data, and
HLA-1 peptomic data. We used
state-of-the-art platforms, such that our
omics data is of high quality and great
depth of coverage across all of them.
So based on the whole genome sequencing and whole exome sequencing data, we
characterized the DNA alteration landscape of the cohort.
We observed a very similar pattern as what's reported in the
literature for melanoma tumors, including the high
frequency of BRAF genes, and NRAS
mutations, as well as CDKN2A deletions.
And we don't observe significant differences between the primary
tumors versus the metastasis tumors in terms of the DNA
alteration pattern.
We performed a comprehensive HLA-1 peptomics
profiling using optimal LS tandem mass
spec to workflow.
We constructed customized sample-specific sequencing
databases to identify unique HLA-1
binding peptides.
The non-chronical ORFs included in this database
has supports from the rigorous
evidence of translation from previous work.
And using this pipeline, we identified more than
300K unique HLA-1 binding peptides,
and we further using very stringent criterion to remove the
peptides that has been ever observed in normal tissue
immunopeptidomics landscape. So this resulted in
identification of 1,138 unique tumor
antigen candidates.
Strikingly, a large percentage of those tumor antigen
candidates were not recorded in the existing IEDB
database, underscoring their novelty as well
as their potential as uncharacterized T cell targets.
In our data, we observed a large variability of the
HLA-1 peptide total counts across tumor samples.
And the HLA-1 peptide total counts also
showed very significant positive correlation with the tumor
antigen number per sample. So this suggests that antigen
presentation drives tumor antigen yield, just as we
expected.
Furthermore, HLA-1 peptide counts per sample also
showed a significant negative correlation with the tumor purity.
So this is consistent with the fact that the tumor cells exhibit
lower presentation than infiltrating cells.What's
more interesting is when we correlate the tumor antigen
counts per sample with the different immune
cell type percentage, the CD8 T cell is the only
cell type that appeared to be significantly correlated
with the tumor antigen counts.
And of course,
we also observed a positive association between the CD8 T
cell
and better survival outcomes among the cohort
who received the immune treatment.
So together, this suggested that higher quality of the antigen
helps with the T cell infiltration.
Moreover, another important observation is that we identified a tenish
of genes whose tumor antigen event happened
in multiple tumors. Specifically, we
identified MAGE A12, 3, and 4 genes,
whose tumor antigen event is significantly associated with
CD8 T cell fraction, and that the more
genes of these three genes got a tumor antigen event
in one sample, the higher CD8 T cell infiltration we observed.
So together, this suggests that there's a direct role of
MAGE A3, 4, 12
genes antigen event contributed to the immunoactive tumor
microenvironment.
Okay, so next I will share a story about
ubiquitin data.
So,
strikingly, 50% of the ubiquitination sites were
identified to be significantly associated with prognosis,
far exceeding the proportion observed in other omics.
And using unsupervised clustering, we
identified a subset of the
tumors with very high ubiquitin level for proteins
from the interferon pathways. And this subgroup has
a significant worse survival outcomes compared to the other.
Pathway characterization shows there's a lot of
pathway perturbations in this interferon UB subgroup compared
to the baseline group.
And we also observed
a different readout based on the global proteomics data versus the
ubiquitin data in terms of the pathway up- and
down-regulation interpretation, suggesting there is a lot of
significant post-translational modification at the ubiquitin level.
Because of the larger change, we
hypothesis there must be some coordinated upstream driver
events,
and that this motivates us to study the E3 ligase, which
are the primary determinants of the substrate
specificity in the ubiquitin system.
By integrating the global and the ubiquitin data, we
identified eight
E3 ligase that is significantly
upregulated in the interferon UB group compared to
the baseline. Further associated those with the substrates
in the ubiquitin data, we identified the two significant pair.
The first pair is the RNF4 protein versus the
ubiquitin size of the DHX9. The second pair
is the BIRC7 protein together with the
AKT1 ubiquitin size. And specifically,
we know AKT1 is a
important oncogene and contributes to cell cycle,
metabolic pathways, and we hypothesis this ubiquitin site
probably contributes to the aggressive phenotype of this interferon
UB subtype.
And in summary, the DHX9 ubiquitin
site together with the AKT1 ubiquitin site are potential
biomarkers for the poor prognosis of the interferon UB subtype.
In the end, I will quickly mention another story we learned using the
glycoproteomics data.
So using the glycoproteomics data,
we identified a subset of tumors with extremely high
lysosome activity.
And this elevation of lysosome activity was supported by other
modality of the data, including metabolomics data, global protein
markers, as well a targeted search for
M6P modified lysosome peptides.
What's interesting about the subtype is that it showed a striking
sex-specific survival outcome. So the
lysosome high subtype in male tumors had
a significantly worse survival. The lysosome high
tumors among female actually has a similar or even better survival
outcome. And this sex-specific
survival association was not confounded by the primary or
metastasis tumor status in our sensitivity analysis.
With further analysis, we identified a leading signature genes of
this lysosome high group,
GPUMB. So this is actually a cell surface marker expressed in
multiple cell types. And this figure illustrated this
opposite association of glycol peptides
of GPUMB,
among male and female. So basically in female it was associated with good
survival,
but in the male it was associated with bad survival, so which is very
intriguing.
Further analysis integrating global proteomics data
and glyco data
further reviewed a specific glycan type.
Fucosylation of the GPUMB is
showing the strongest sex differential
association with a bunch of pathways.
And we don't see this in the other glycan type.
And more importantly, we observed that in females,
the total GPUMB fucosylation score was
positively associated with a CD8 T cell fraction,
and then negatively associated with CD276
level, which is a immune inhibitor marker,
only in the females, but not in the males.
So this is suggesting that there's a-A
striking sex-relevant role of GPM1B
fucosylation.
And more exciting,
we noticed that there's another talk tomorrow actually at AACR
meeting that reporting this very exciting
GPM1B CAR T cell, usage of that in the
GBM tumors.
So in summary, we reported a comprehensive
atlas
of multi-omics data for melanoma, and we believe this is a
valuable resources will enable us to recover underlying
disease mechanisms and identify biomarkers.
Specifically, we reported
many novel tumor antigens identified from our
HLA peptomics data, and we provide a
direct connection between the tumor antigen of MHA
3412 genes and CD8 T cell infiltration.
And using the ubiquitin data, we identified
important
prognostic markers. And using the glycoproteomics data, we
reviewed sex-specific biology.
In the end, I want to thank the collaborators in this study,
especially Dr.
Tao Liu, Dr. Marcin Cieslik. So they are the
co-PIs of this study, and we have many
talented team members has contributed significantly.
I will stop here and hopefully take some questions.
Thank you so much, Dr. Wan, for such a comprehensive data of nice beautiful
presentation. Due to the time constraint, I would like to take one
question.
So I think this is a very important study.
Obviously, immunotherapies, plural,
are one of the big accomplishments of the cancer research community in the last two
decades.
And it's been quite puzzling why we don't have higher
success rates. As you said, majority of patients-
Only 40 to 60
... even with melanoma. Melanoma is the best.
Yeah. Already the best.
Even so, it's less than 50% have a durable
good response.
So I'm curious,
in the slide, if you go back about three or four slides,
this one,
where you show the androgen receptor
pathway. So not androgen receptor itself, but androgen
receptor pathway, I think.
Here?
No.
No, much later.
Oh.
Oh, here?
No.
One more.
More.
I don't think there's another.
I had it just a minute ago.
That
is about the glycol.
There it is right there.
Oh, here. You mean their interaction between GP-
In the last
red dot on the left side.
Right.
Yes.
So right. So here is what we suspect. Okay.
I don't know whether this relates to your question, but to explain this figure,
this is illustrating how the
fucosylation of GPM1B have
a significant sex differential role
in the tumor, that it was correlated with those
sex hormone related pathways only in the female tumors,
but not in the male tumors. And we suspect that
probably relates to the different treatment response actually between
the two sex group
among the melanoma patient.
So you think it's the androgen receptor difference or the
fucosylation is different?
Oh, we think it's the fucosylation
differences.
That their interplay changes. It's
like in the male, probably this fucosylation peptide is
doing something else. But in the female, it was interacting with the sex
hormone pathway.
Okay. So what we'd like to do with these kinds of results is
figure out
a companion therapy-
Yes
... that would in fact drive success for the
40 plus percent, 50 plus percent who do not have a durable
response.
Right. Exactly. So that is what our hypothesis here is that the
male patient in this subgroup, which has this
GPM1B
elevated peptide level, might
be suitable for some
GPM1B targeted treatment that has been very
actively started right now.
Yeah.
Hope so. Good.
Okay. I hope so. Yeah. Towards precision medicine.
For different group of people, we need different treatment.
Thanks for the question.
Okay. Thank you so much.
Now I would like to introduce the third speaker, Dr.
Jorge Ledesma. Dr. Ledesma is from a division of
research, Kaiser Permanente, Northern California.
His presentation title is Endocrine Therapy Adherence and
10-Year Risk of Cardiometabolic Outcomes Among
Women with Hormone Receptor-Positive Breast Cancer.
Please join me in welcoming Dr. Ledesma.
All right. Thanks, everyone. Yeah, my name is Jorge.
Super excited to present some of the work I've been doing looking at the link
between endocrine therapy adherence and long-term cardiometabolic health among
breast cancer survivors. With that, I'll go ahead and get started.
Really briefly, here are my disclosures.
All right. So overall, breast cancer is the most common invasive cancer among
women in the United States. It's estimated that one in eight will
eventually develop breast cancer at some point in their lives.
And currently, there's well over four million breast cancer survivors today, with
that number projected to be growing every single year from here on out.
It's estimated that about 70 to 80% of all cases are hormone receptor positive, and
so this means that tumor growth is being stimulated by a patient's own estrogen or
progesteroneIn the common sort of treatment pathway, at least for kind
of early-stage hormone receptor-positive breast cancer, is that shortly after
diagnosis, patients go through surgery followed by chemotherapy or
radiation therapy whenever indicated.
And then from there, for the next five to 10 years, they're on endocrine therapies
to prevent the cancer from coming back.
And as the presentation title suggests, we'll be focusing on endocrine therapies
for this presentation.
Currently, there are two main types of endocrine therapies.
The first one being aromatase inhibitors, or AIs for short, and these function by
preventing estrogen production in the body.
And then the second one being tamoxifen, or TAM for short, and these function by
blocking estrogen from attaching to cancer cells.
And currently, nowadays, AIs tend to be a bit more commonly prescribed, but the
selection between the two largely depends on patients based on cancer risk,
on a patient and clinician preferences, as well as a patient's kind of baseline
menopausal status as well. And both therapies have been shown to be
incredibly efficacious. They substantially improve survival, at the same time, they
substantially reduce the opportunity for cancer reoccurrences.
But they definitely have their fair share of side effects, and so both therapies
are associated with increased hot flashes, fatigue, and joint pain.
In the case of aromatase inhibitors, they tend to have a bit more severe side
effects in that they're associated with increased bone loss that can lead to hip
fractures, and as well as potential cardiovascular disease risk, which is sort of
the main focus of this project here.
And then tamoxifen has actually been shown to be somewhat cardioprotective as well,
which is interesting. And overall, because of the various side effects
associated with both therapies, adherence varies widely across studies and
settings. Some studies report five-year adherence as low as 20%, others as
high as 80%. And so for this study, we sort of want to leverage the wide
variation in adherence to assess how different sort of endocrine therapy
durations of use or how different kind of endocrine therapy types are shaping kind
of long-term cardiometabolic health among breast cancer survivors.
And we hope that this work can provide a better picture of how these two therapies
are kind of impacting downstream cardiovascular disease risk among the growing
breast cancer survivor population.
So let's go ahead and jump into some of the main methods for the project.
So this project has sort of three main research objectives.
The first is that we want to assess how different durations of endocrine therapy
are impacting 10-year risk of cardiometabolic outcomes.
And then since we know that these two different therapies exist, so we're going to
assess how these associations differ by therapy type, so
aromatase inhibitors versus tamoxifen.
And then lastly, to kind of better contextualize the harms and benefits of
endocrine therapy, we're going to assess how different adherence levels are
impacting breast cancer-specific mortality as well as overall mortality as
well. So let's take a deeper dive into some of the study design considerations
for this project. So this was a prospective cohort study within the Kaiser
Permanente Northern California healthcare delivery system.
The enrollment was between 2005 to about March 2013, and the
study ended at the end of 2021. We include all Kaiser members
with their first-ever diagnosis of Stage 1, 2, or 3 hormone receptor-positive
breast cancer. It included all women who were post-menopausal.
And also we included those who had at least one year of continuous membership as
well, and time zero or follow-up would immediately begin once a patient initiated
their endocrine therapy.
For this study, we had two sort of main exposure variables, the first one being
exposure to any endocrine therapy.
So for this first exposure variable, we're kind of lumping together both AIs and
TAMs together. In our second exposure variable, we kind of separate them out a
little bit. So it's a three-level variable, one for AI use, a second one for
TAM, and the third one being exposure to neither.
And then to assess adherence to each therapy, we use what's called a proportion of
days covered metric. And so this means that for any given year, if a patient had
enough drug supply to cover 80% of that year, then patient would be
considered as adherent or exposed for that given year.
And then to assess cardiometabolic health, we had three sort of main outcome
variables: hypertension, dyslipidemia, and diabetes as well.
And then to estimate treatment effects, we use what's called sequentially doubly
robust estimation or SDR for short.
I could talk about SDR for hours, but I definitely don't want to put everyone to
sleep today. And so very briefly, SDR is a really powerful
semiparametric, doubly robust estimator of causal effects.
It combines the two most popular approaches in causal inference, which is g
computation, as well as propensity score estimation.
At the same time, to model both these parameters allows us to use modern machine
learning methods.
SDR is really great because, as the name suggests, it's doubly robust, and at the
same time, it provides really kind of easy to understand, really clinically
relevant outputs, and that provides us adjusted cumulative incidents.
And I think you'll see the utility of that in the next coming slides as well.
So let's go ahead and take a deeper dive now into some of the key results.
So overall, we were able to include well over 8,000 patients into our original
cohort. About 40% of the cohort were considered to be
long-term users of endocrine therapy.
So these are people who are adherent to endocrine therapies for at least five or
more years. And so when we compare long-term users compared to those who are
non-adherent, long-term users tend to be younger, tend to
reside in neighborhoods with kind of higher medium incomes and higher education
levels, and also are more likely to receive chemotherapy and radiation therapy
compared to those who are non-adherent.
As well, the long-term users tend to be a bit more healthier in that they had fewer
kind of co-occurring conditions at baseline as well.
So let's go ahead and take a deeper dive into some of the key findings now.
So this first slide is showing the results for hypertension, and one of the main
findings here is that longer adherence to endocrine therapy was associated with
greater risk of hypertension. So you can see here the 10-year risk for those that
were non-adherent was about 20% for one year, 23% for
four years, 26%, and those adherent for five or more years or five years exactly
rather, the 10-year risk of hypertension was about 29%.
So comparing those adherent for five years compared to those who are non-adherent,
the absolute risk increase is about 9%.
And I found very similar results for dyslipidemia as well, where longer adherence
was associated with greater risk as well.
You'll see here the 10-year risk on the table to the right for those who are
non-adherent, about 26%, 25% for one year, 30%
for four years, and pretty close to 31% for those adherent for five
years. So again, comparing those adherent to their therapy for five years compared
to those who are non-adherent, the absolute risk about 5% greater for these
patients. And then very similar results for diabetes as well.
Again, longer adherence was associated with greater risk of diabetes.
So the 10-year risk for those who are non-adherent was about 9.5%, for
four years, 11%, and 12 years, 12%, which
corresponded to cumulative incidence difference about 2.6 percentage points
greater among those adherent for five years compared to those who are not adherent.
And so this first set of results, we're kind of lumping together AIs and TAMs
together. And so in our second analysis, we want to assess how
these results could differ by endocrine therapy type.
So let's have a look at what we found.So, in the case of hypertension, we actually
didn't find much of a difference between aromatase inhibitors and tamoxifen.
You can see here that the 10-year risk for hypertension for people who use neither
was about 20%, TAM users about over 29%, and very similarly
for the aromatase inhibitor users, about 29% as well.
So compared to those who weren't adherent to any endocrine therapy, the risk was
about 9% greater on the absolute scale.
However, when we looked at dyslipidemia, results started to
kind of be a little bit more different.
So for dyslipidemia, we found that AI use was
associated with greater risk, but definitely not the case with tamoxifen.
So you can see here the 10-year risk among those who are non-adherent was about
26%, almost, among AI users 33%, and tamoxifen users about
23%. So at least for this outcome,
AI use was associated with increased risk, but definitely not the case with
tamoxifen. And very similar results for diabetes as well, where we found AI
use was associated with greater risk, but not the case for tamoxifen.
You'll see here that the 10-year risk for those who are non-adherent was about
9.5%, for AI users nearly 13%, and for
TAM users about 9.9%.
And so as a final kind of analysis for this project,
we kind of want to better contextualize the harms and benefits of endocrine
therapy. So for this secondary analysis, we want to assess how adherence is
associated with mortality outcomes.
So if you look at the figure to the far left, we looked at mortality from all
causes. Patients who are non-adherent had a 10-year risk of
mortality about 28%, but for both AI and TAM users, about
18%. And then when we looked at breast cancer-specific mortality on the right, you
can see here that among patients who are non-adherent, 10-year risk of
breast cancer-specific mortality was around 13%, about, I would say,
maybe 8% for tamoxifen users and about 6% for AI users.
So when it comes to breast cancer-specific mortality, AI users, or I guess the
use of AIs, was a bit more effective here.
And so finally, to quickly wrap things up, so overall, we found that aromatase
inhibitor use was associated with increased risk of hypertension, dyslipidemia, and
diabetes. Tamoxifen, on the other hand, was only associated with increased risk of
hypertension. However, both therapies were associated with marked reduction to
mortality, and therefore, these findings really emphasize the importance of being
able to maintain adherence to endocrine therapy, while also being able to
monitor really closely cardiometabolic health to better optimize
overall outcomes for our growing population of breast cancer
survivors. Yeah, that's what I all have. Thanks for listening, everyone. Thanks.
Thank you very much, Dr. Ledesma.
Now we'll open the floor for questions.
Please.
Okay.
Hi. Sorry. Great
study. I was wondering,
right now the recommendation is to take the aromatase
inhibitors and stuff like that for about 10 years.
Yep.
What do you think is the updated recommendation based on your findings?
Yeah.
Especially also for after 10 years, is there any
coherent data that you have found?
Yeah, that's a really great question.
And so when we initial enrolled the cohort, the standard of care at that
time was five years. And so that's why kind of for this analysis, we focused on the
five-year period. But I think in a follow-up study, we'd definitely want to
move it up to 10 years, because judging by our results, longer adherence is
associated with increased risk. So there is a potential that the longer a patient's
on their aromatase inhibitor, the higher the risk could be.
And so that's definitely an area for future research for this sort of work.
But that's a great question.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you for that very nice talk.
Forgive me for a bit of a naive question, but trying to think about how to square
the increased risk for taking
either tamoxifen or aromatase inhibitors with the overall lower or
better overall survival outcomes.
Yeah.
Were you able to control for the frequency of
screenings for CV in the adherent and non-adherent?
Are people who are staying on treatment seeing their doctor more often?
Yeah, a little bit. So at baseline, we definitely control for
healthcare access. That's a really good point.
But I think we could do better about controlling it throughout follow-up, because
perhaps during follow-up, patients may be more likely to go to healthcare and
stuff like that. So yeah, that's definitely a
potential limitation here is that we can't control,
through every single year, how likely patients are able to go to
see their healthcare provider. But that is something we do control at baseline at
the very least.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Well, this is an important study. More and more women are in this category.
But there's one other variable you didn't mention, which is
pharmacogenomics.
Mm-hmm.
So the tamoxifen
has to be metabolized
to
endoxifen
metabolite, which is the
active-
Mm-hmm
... form.
And
there was a lot of variation in the cytochrome P450
2D6.
Oh, yep.
And there's also a complication in the analysis because there's a 2D7 and
2D8, which are inactive homologues.
Is that something you are aware of and have a strategy for trying to-
Yeah, yeah
... analyze and get the assays done?
I think that'll probably be like a-
Our view is that it's an important part of characterizing the patient.
Yeah, I think that'll be a future area for research.
For those newer therapies you just mentioned, CTD and the other ones,
they came about after the cohort was enrolled.
But yeah, I think that's definitely something to look at here for this project.
Yeah, the differences in standard populations here are quite
significant.
Absolutely.
Great. So,
thank you so much for a wonderful presentation, and I think
having the
estrogen receptor degraders now in market.
So, I'm sure you're collecting the data and show us
in the future. Thank you.
All right. We're going to change microphones.
So can Bill
please come up? There you are. All right.
So I'm going to present the next speaker.
This is Bill DiPlas from Memorial Sloan Kettering
Cancer Center, from the Department of Radiation Oncology in New York
City. And his title is "Comprehensive Phenotypic
Mapping of ALT
Regulation Expands the Landscape of Targetable Suppressors."
Thanks very much to the organizers for this opportunity to speak about our
work.
My name is Bill DiPlas, and I'm a physician scientist in radiation oncology at
Sloan Kettering, and I'm excited to discuss our ongoing work in
understanding the regulation of this pathway alternative lengthening of telomeres,
otherwise known as ALT.
These are my disclosures.
So telomere maintenance mechanisms are universal to cancer, a hallmark
allowing for replicative immortality.
While the majority of cancers activate telomerase,
whose activity allows for addition of telomeric repeats to the ends of chromosomes,
approximately 10% of cancers use this ALT pathway.
This is telomerase independent, and it relies on recombination
to elongate telomeres.
And so ALT is specifically present in several key
histologies. These include malignant gliomas, pancreatic neuroendocrine
tumors, as well as soft tissue sarcomas and
osteosarcoma and neuroblastoma.
From sequencing studies over the past decades, ALT tumors have been found to be
associated with a number of ALT drivers.
Namely, these include loss of function mutations in ATRX and DAXX,
which lead to a loss of protein expression, which I'm showing on the right here.
And in addition, what's known about these is that they normally
deposit H3.3 at the telomeres, and this helps to protect against
replication stress and recombination.
There are a number of key hallmarks used for ALT phenotyping,
and to identify tumors with this phenotype.
And also namely to track ALT activity.
And so
these include
long heterogeneous telomeres that are detected by denatured FISH, as well
as ALT-associated PML bodies, otherwise known as APBs, which are made up of
PML protein that is simulated to form these hubs of recombination
that are really at the core of ALT recombination.
These contain repair factors along with
telomere ends that are critical, again, for the ALT
activity. Lastly, single-strand DNA present
on telomere gaps and C-circles are also critical to ALT activity
and specific to it, and these can be detected by native FISH.
This is also known as SSTOC.
And so in terms of the underlying mechanisms of ALT, a number of factors have been
implicated in this pathway, and as I said before, most of them are related to DNA
repair and recombination. However, the exact mechanism of this pathway is
not fully understood. What we do know is that all telomeres are prone to
significant replication stress,
usually due to the accumulation of secondary structures of the telomeres that make
them difficult to replicate.
And ALT seems to have similarities to break-induced replication or
BIR.
And so we've been able to map through the studies of many
groups, a number of ALT promoters and ALT suppressors.
I've underlined some of the most important ones.
Bloom, which is a part of the BTR complex, helps resolve recombination
intermediates, and also FANCM, which resolves R-loops at
telomeres and prevents fork stalling.
So
there's a lot of clinical interest in targeting these, and most of the clinical
interest is in targeting the suppressors, which usually lead to a hyper-ALT
phenotype and then cell death.
And so I like this visualization of this.
So to maintain ALT activity, it requires a balance of these factors.
And so
you need some level of baseline DNA replication stress to initiate telomere
elongation. However, when this is too high, the balance is tipped towards this
hyper-ALT phenotype, which is lethal in cells.
And again, there's a lot of recent clinical interest in this.
As you can see from notable papers
that showed that ATR is a target in alternative lengthening of telomeres
positive cells, and usually again, leading towards tipping this balance towards
the hyper-ALT phenotype. And this was recently published
this past year, a patient that was treated with an ATR inhibitor with metastatic
melanoma who had an exceptional response to the drug.
And so clearly, there's a lot of work done to further identify novel factors in
this area. In line with this, our hypothesis was
if we could leverage ALT phenotypes in the context of genome-wide screening to map
the regulatory landscape of alternative lengthening of telomeres in cancer.
And so
to do this, we realized we needed to develop a new tool.
Native FISH, which I mentioned before, is ALT specific
and tracks with ALT activity. And as you can see below from cells growing on a
dish, when you knock down Bloom, it has a
lead to a decreased phenotype of ALT
FISH. And then when you knock out FANCM, you have an increased
hyper-ALT phenotype compared to the NTC control, and this is in U2OS.
And so what we decided to do is take this native FISH approach, and after
significant optimization, develop it into a flow-based readout of
single-cell ALT activity. We're calling this Alt-Flow-FISH.
And using this, we were able to show that we can discriminate these same
promoters from ALT suppressors, but this time in a
flow-based manner and at scale.
Given this, we expanded this to a genome-wide CRISPR screen in two ALT lines,
U2OS and RP-ALT, using the genome-wide library TKOv3.
Following selection, we performed Alt-Flow-FISH only after four days and
sorted the highest and lowest populations in terms of native FISH
signal. We did this in an effort to specifically map ALT
promoters and suppressors, rather than what you're probably used to seeing,
which is a typical viability screen using these CRISPR genome-wide
approaches.And so
interestingly, what we found is that when we
intentionally chose the early time point specifically to try to find both
essential and non-essential genes.
And interestingly, what we found is that if you map out
genes that were labeled as suppressors and promoters, actually
among the suppressors, there were many essential genes that would have otherwise
been missed if we had used viability as an endpoint.
And then when we look at this
across the genome, we see that a number of controls
come out as validation that our screen is working, including the BTR complex,
as I mentioned before, as a promoter and as a suppressor of FANCM.
And what's interesting from this is also that we found that there's a kind of a
downward shift of the curve, where there are many more ALT suppressors
identified from this assay, which may be also due to some technical reasons for
detection purposes.
We did pathway analysis on all the hits from this screen and found that a number of
factors related to DNA repair, replication, and cell cycle, but also novel
pathways, including the proteasome and fanconi anemia pathways.
And so I've shown these two here, and we chose to focus on
these two key pathways because they were less well-characterized in terms of their
role in ALT. I'll be focusing primarily today on our work related to the
proteasome, just due to time. And notably, among
these proteasome hits, we found both structural components of the proteasome,
including PSMB1, PSMB5, 6, among others.
But we also found akirin 2, which was recently identified as
a factor responsible for nuclear import of the proteasome, which would be in line
with what we might expect for this phenotype as well.
And so we first independently designed guides targeting the top hits from the
screen and validated them using native fish on coverslips.
And we see clearly that these had a classic ALT suppressor phenotype, very similar
to what we see with FANCM.
And then we used an orthogonal assay, which is cCircle detection,
and found that again, we see similar to FANCM, an ALT suppressor
phenotype in components of the proteasome and fanconi anemia pathways.
Again, inducing this hyper ALT phenotype, and that this gave us really confidence
that these were true ALT suppressors.
And so we were particularly interested in following up on the proteasome and
understanding why it was acting as an ALT suppressor.
Our first thought was that the loss of the proteasome was believed to build up of
telomeric proteins and that this might drive ALT.
Notably, we found, again, the structural components as well as akirin 2, which is
responsible, again, for the nuclear import of the proteasomes.
And so this was kind of our initial thought that this would lead to hyper ALT and
then presumably cell death in that case.
So to ask this question more broadly, what we did is total proteome mass
spectrometry using TMT at 48 hours following depletion of these
components using CRISPR. And what we found, and this is
in an ALT cell line. And so what we found is that this surprisingly
led to significant buildup of PML protein and other components of the
key ALT-associated PML body, the APB, which I mentioned before is this hub
driving recombination at the telomeres.
We performed Western blot in ALT cell lines and found that
we confirmed the specific buildup of PML protein upon
proteasome depletion.
Next, we confirmed that
when we drive PML overexpression using a lentiviral vector that is
dox-inducible, this induces a hyper ALT phenotype by
cCircles in U2OS. And interestingly, we
found that this also leads to cell death when overexpressed compared to a
control GFP induction.
Lastly, we explored use of a proteasome inhibitor, bortezomib, which is actually
used clinically in ALT lines, and found that treatment actually led, again, to this
hyper ALT phenotype consistent with our previous data.
So in summary, we developed a method that allows for single-cell ALT activity
detection by flow cytometry. We leveraged this to perform the first genome-wide
screen of ALT activity. And using this, we were able to map out the key
pathways implicated in ALT, including both known and unknown pathways.
Using mass spectrometry, we found that the proteasome inhibition is actually
leading to accumulation of components of the APB,
the key hub for recombination and ALT activity.
And we found that direct overexpression of PML leads to this hyper ALT phenotype
and cell death in our cell line models, and that we can recapitulate this phenotype
using proteasome inhibitors.
And so these approaches we hope may inform future targeting strategies
for ALT cancers.
And with that, I'd like to thank the organizers, my lab, and our collaborators at
MSKCC, and elsewhere, as well as my funding.
Thanks.
While people get...
Okay, go ahead.
Okay, Bill. Great work.
Thanks.
Yeah. So a quick question. So how homogeneous are those
ALT, kind of just like the single-cell
ALT, your readout can see in the cell line,
right?
Yeah.
So how homogeneous they are?
They're not that homogeneous if we apply this technology for
more heterogeneous model.
Right.
We still use this to do the screening.
That's a great question. So the group that kind of initially developed the assay
also kind of characterized some of these kind of probes.
And what they found is that it is quite heterogeneous, and it also is cell line
dependent. So U2OS is very ALT-positive-
Mm
... and it has a different kind of threshold, I would call it, or baseline
level of ALT activity. There's a distribution, of course.
Mm.
But then our diploid engineered ALT model, this RPE ALT line,
it shows a more muted ALT phenotype.
So we found kind of similar hits across both cell lines, but
I think that's something we're interested in doing, is kind of looking more closely
at the cells that happen to be bigger hubs for this activity and
why that might be or why it isn't the case.
Thank you.
Thanks.
I have a similar question.
Yeah.
So this is fantastic, the ALT flow FISH.
Yes, thanks.
Mind-blowing. So I was wondering whether
you have, first of all,
planned to go to try and demonstrate this in the
neuroblastoma, glioma, and the PANETs.
Yes.
And if so, are you thinking of using something like this for
diagnostics?
So,
this is actively being... I would say that it's becoming a more and more
routine assay for use in characterizing some of these tissue types.
But the foundational studies done by other groups were done using the denatured
FISH, and those were done on large cohorts of tumors.
And so I think it needs to be done. It's a key question in
how variable this is between tumor histologies.
We are interested in, along the same lines of your question,
doing the same flow FISH assay in different cancer cell lines
from these tissues to see if there is some tissue differences
in terms of ALT activity in both promoters and suppressors of ALT
by cancer type.
It's fascinating. Go ahead.
Yeah, you showed that nice
clinical data with the ATR inhibitor in the patient,
but I didn't see ATR come up in your screen.
I saw FANCM and some other common players.
I didn't know, did you see ATR come up there or?
We did see ATR and other components in ATR, ETA A1, things like that
in the same pathway. I just didn't show it as a...
I only pointed to the most notable controls, I guess-
Okay
... like NGM and Bloom.
But other things, ATR pathway members-
Yes
... were in there. Okay.
All in the suppressor-
Side
... side, yeah. Great question.
If we have a little more time, can you expand on the
nuclear
transport blocking?
Yeah.
How significant? What does that mean
to the biology?
Yeah. So it's interesting, we weren't really initially
familiar with its role of ikurin-2, but another group had published
a paper in "Nature" about four to five years ago, complete different purpose,
actually tracking Myc
levels in the cell. But had this interesting finding that this protein that was
very poorly characterized, ikurin-2, happened to be, they found,
regulating Myc levels by actually controlling the transport of the
proteasome into the nucleus. And so it was kind of a nice...
We like it because it's a bit of a more specific proteasome targeting factor,
for our purposes, because we're looking at a nuclear phenotype.
And so we use them side by side with direct proteasome inhibition, as well as this
knockout of ikurin-2.
But clearly, I think the punchline from the APB work that we did is
that we think that the tight regulation of levels of these
factors is actually really important to telomere maintenance,
and that too much, again, pushes that balance to the hyper-ALT phenotype
very rapidly and can be lethal. And so this is
another level of regulation that we think is important for this phenotype.
Great. Okay, one more.
Yeah. Actually, I forgot to ask one important question.
So based on what you just said, the hyper-ALT phenotype
and also
tumor cells use those to maintain telomere length, right?
So from your current thinking, so could you share some
insights? How can we leverage this ALT mechanism
to really make the
cancer treatment more effective? Yeah.
I think it's a great question. There's a lot of interest in trying to drug ALT
because it's
cancer specific, whereas, drugging telomerase is a much more challenging feat
due to expression in other tissues.
However, a lot of the factors that underlie ALT are still common
to DNA repair combinations. So, you have to have a
window to target it, and I think we're still trying to find that.
We're trying to explore how much proteasome inhibition can be used
directly to target ALT cells. Alternatively, we're looking into things like
stabilizing PML as another way to drug
or degrade the degraders of PML to help more
specifically target ALT cancers.
Thank you.
All right. Let's thank Bill. Thank you so much.
All right. Our next speaker, and I apologize for butchering your name
already.
Xiaoyu Zhao.
Yes.
She is a postdoctoral fellow at the
University of San Diego, so she didn't travel so far.
Yeah.
And the talk title is Protein Complex Remodeling in
Metastatic Breast Cancer Cells.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Thanks for the opportunity to speak here. So my name is Xiaoyu.
I'm a postdoc fellow at Dr. Troy Atticher
lab
in UCSD.
So today, I'm sharing
an ongoing work
about how protein complex are remodeler in
metastatic breast cancer cells
in response to chemotherapy.
So as we know, when we treat patients, so the cancer therapy
not just
simply target individual molecules like
proteins. It always reshape the
organization of the whole cell.
And this reorganization actually is very important
because it will determine whether the cancer cell
can respond to the treatment or fail.
But so far, it's still
the protein complex
reorganization at a system level is still lacking
there.
So to address this
problem-We
profile the protein organization information
using different experimental platforms in
triple-negative breast cancer cells
under the untreated condition and across
two other treated conditions, including the vernostat
and the paclitaxel treatment. So in this study,
we focused on a group of proteins, including
hundreds of chromatin modifiers and its
interaction partners and
other several hundred of the drug-responsive proteins or
drug-responsive proteins. So we profile
the
protein localization in cells using the
confocal microscopy technology, and we also profile
the protein interactions using the mass spec
technology. In addition, we also profile the functional
states, the cell states, using the single-cell prototypic
data. So why
we want to collect multimodal data to study the protein
complex because
each data modality
alone is not enough. Each modality captures the protein
organization at a different resolution or from
different perspective. The different resolution,
it can be from the nanomolar to
micromolar. So the
different perspective, it can be structural or can be functional.
So, a couple of recent works in the
Artiko Lab have already shown the integration of different
modality data can
capture the detailed organization of the
proteins
or can build a
literal call can
be like a virtual cell here. And the work here that
also show the virtual cell can
be a foundation to
link the genomics to the end of the
functions,
including how the mutation alteration in a
complex can affect the patient
response to different treatments.
But so far, all these maps are -- the existing cell maps are
static.
They did not capture the treatment-specific
dynamics or remodeling.
So that's what our project about. So
first, we use the image,
the confocal,
to
profile, to capture how a protein changes
their localization in a cell. So giving you example here,
so the histone deacetylate 8, the
HDAC8, in untreated condition, it
localized. It's
located broadly in both
cytosol and nucleus. But
after the paclitaxel treatment,
it moved to nucleus primarily. We profile the
protein localization information for over 400
proteins across
this untreated and the two other treated conditions.
And we also profile the protein interactions,
using the IP-MS,
of
chromatin
modifiers.
Giving you example here.
So you can see the interaction partners of the different protein can
change in response to different treatments.
So the HDAC1 here, the gray
nodes here, it's a shared
interaction partner across the conditions.
And the blue ones and the red nodes are the dynamic
interaction partners in different conditions.
And to go beyond the pairwise protein interactions, we also
use the SEC-MS, the size exclusion chromatography
mass spec to profile the protein complex at a
system level.
So
basically in the SEC-MS,
the proteins co-elute across a fraction
together are likely to be part of a complex.
So after measuring,
profiling the
image,
the
subcellular localization,
and the protein interaction networks, and also the functional state
across the conditions of over 900
proteins,
we integrate all this information together. So how we did that?
So, basically, we built a self-supervised deep learning
model and embed each protein into a shared
latent space. So
with this, we can make
each protein from different modality.
Each
modality become consistent so
that we can compare them directly, then build
to identify the dynamic pattern across the
treatment so that we can
identify the
dynamic protein complex in the
cells.So with the
integrated representation
for the over 900 proteins, including mostly
the chromate modifiers and its interaction partners and
some other proteins. So we
do the class, the proteins. We did the community
detection, basically find the groups for these proteins and build
a hierarchical map of the protein complex.
So,
this protein organization here, we show it in a
nested way. So basically, the individual
protein with high shared features across different
modalities will be grouped into a node, a small node, which is
a small protein complex. And the protein small
complex they can even further group into a bigger
protein assembly and/or even
that can be further into a organelle
or functional group.
So this integration and analysis enable us
to identify over 100 protein complexes for those
900 proteins, including
almost half
novel and is no protein complex or
assemblance there.
So the next question is, what's the dynamic, right?
So since we have
the
data profiled across two chemotherapy
treatment conditions. So we literally can compare the organization of
these proteins at different conditions.
Then with that, we
can construct a hierarchical map of a dynamic
map. So we can classify these protein assemblance
into stable or dynamic. So the dynamic can
either be this protein complexes are uniformed in a
new treatment condition or this complex can be
just disappeared in a treated condition.
So here are just some representative examples of the protein
complex.
So in each heat map, so the more red
you see, they are
either more interactive or associated in a
complex. We group them into a complex.
So one example here is the stress response
assembly only gained, like specifically gained in
vernal stat treated cells.
And we also found some other interesting
complex. For example, here the CBPP300.
This is a transcriptional activation complex which only
specifically get in paclitaxel treated
cells. And here's another example show
you here the trap associated SWI/SNF
chromatin regulatory complex are lost in
both treatments.
So this is still ongoing project. So right now
to summarize, basically we provide a larger scale, like a
multi-omics data, like from imaging to the
proteomics and the single-cell, the transcriptome mix
data,
in response to the chemotherapy treatments.
And we integrate the deeper learning
models and combine all this data together and build the
hierarchical cell map and identify interesting dynamic
complex. So for my long-term goal, this is still
ongoing. So the next step, the ongoing step right now is
we want to link this dynamic complex
to the functional outcomes, especially
in a patient survival in response to different treatments.
Eventually, we want to target, hopefully, we can
target, like find a targetable
complex to build them, make them targetable.
This dynamic protein complex for combinatory therapy
especially for the chemo-resistant in metastatic breast
cancer patients.
With that, this is like a
consortium. So
I want to thank my advisor, Trey, is here, and also
many other people, especially in the data generation group from
different groups from the proteomics data
from Nevin's group,
UCSF, and single-cell data from
Prashant's lab at UCSD, and the image data
from Emma Lemberg lab at Stanford.
And of course, the funding source, the Cell Map.
With that, I would like to take any question. Thank you.
So great talk, actually. I have two question about the
protein-protein interaction.
Mm-hmm.
I think first one, I see it as like a three... Oh, yeah, that slide.
The three method, the overlap is...
So I think after that slide, you have like a Venn diagram,
three overlap.
I think overlap is at 80 or something.
So, I mean, which one is reliable based on your
model? I think one diagram on the left
is okay. And the second-
This one?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah. I mean, what is the reliable number you
think?
I think slide-
One more?
Yes. Yeah, this one.
Uh-huh.
You can see the overlap is like 82, and in this
scenario which protein-protein interaction
considered to be the most reliable one, or you
only consider 82? So this is my first question.
And the second question is, I noticed you use like
AP and SEC to study the
protein-protein interaction. And probably these two process
will first lyse the cell and then-Yeah, you
analyze the protein-protein interaction.
So how to make sure during this, like a cell lysis,
the protein-protein interaction is the real in the
in vivo cell, not during the lysis process. Thank you.
Oh, okay. So first to the second question.
So, like you're talking about, so first, the data collection
is from a different group. So you kind of have a
concern about the transition,
interactions-
Yeah
... during, due to the lysis process.
Is that your concern?
Yeah. For example, like affinity.
Right.
Yeah. You first lyse the cell, and then whether this
protein complex is from after lyse or in the native,
like in vivo.
Mm-hmm. I think that's a great question.
So, I think
that's kind of the limit of the APMS, its own
limit of the APMS technology, right?
So,
I think I don't have solution for the APMS, but I
think there must be some other technology can capture the
transient interaction probably in future we can integrate this kind of
data into this so that we can make even a
comprehensive, the protein organization,
including both the, how do I say, the
transient or
a very strong interactions. Yeah.
Right.
Yes. Back to your first question.
So are you...
What's the question?
I think that's a technical question.
Oh.
And she didn't do that. It's from her collaborator, so
maybe you can talk offline, just so
we keep this for-
Yeah. Okay.
I'm sorry. Didn't mean to be mean. I
do have another question, maybe fast.
The commonality that you found with the TRAP-associated,
what's the name? Oh, sweet sniff.
Sweet sniff.
Yeah.
So do you have any plan to
check or verify whether these are drivers
that are in common or whether these are
biomarkers that are bystanders?
Yeah.
Be good for targeting.
I kind of have a pretty detailed plan on
my to-do list. So we have some other data, for
example, like the pharmacogenomics data.
We can leverage this kind of data to see whether those
are real biomarker for the
response. So,
with the
cell data or even patient data, we can go into the patient
data. So,
that's kind of the long-term goal.
Good. That's very exciting.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Thank you.
Let's thank her. Thank you very much.
All right. So our next speaker is Daniella
Garcia from the Greehey Children's Cancer
Center Institute, Mays Cancer Center in UT San Antonio,
and she is going to be talking about targeting
EYA4, and the fact that it disrupts the genome
stability in triple negative breast cancer.
They're going to pop up.
You move with the green thingy and use the mouse.
They're right there.
Yeah, you're ready.
Oh, those are the old slides. Do you
want to go last and we can put the next talk?
Yeah, but how do we put it up there? You need to go...
You need to go to the video. So can we...
Is it possible to replace with a new slide set?
There was a new slide set.
Is this the new one?
No, they don't know. So do you want to go back and talk to
them and we will go with Dr. Orr?
Is that okay?
Sure, we can just swap.
Yeah, we just swap. That way we don't disturb the whole thing.
Just go talk with them, and hopefully we'll figure it out.
Thank you for accommodating that.
All right. So I'm going to present Dr. Orr. One second.
So our next speaker, and we're improvising,
is Mark Orr.
He is from Astellas Pharma Global Development in
Seattle, Washington.
And, he's in collaboration with Astellas
Pharma from Japan. Oh, this is really interesting.
Okay, sorry.
Yeah, we need to talk later, too.
The talk is entitled
ASP2998-TROP2
Targeted Immunomodulatory Antibody Drug Conjugate or
Inhibitor ADC
with Dual Payloads Which Demonstrate
Potent Efficacy and Favorable Safety Profile in
Non-Clinical Models.
Go ahead.
Thank you very much. And on behalf of myself, my colleagues at
Astellas, as well as our partners at Sutro, thank you to the AACR
for the invitation to present today on our exciting
platform.So these are my disclosures.
And just to briefly introduce Trop-2, our target
antigen, which is a type I transmembrane glycoprotein
that's involved in a number of different intracellular signaling pathways,
including proliferation, migration, and invasion of cancer cells.
And overexpression of Trop-2 correlates with poor prognosis
in a number of different tumor types, including urothelial,
non-small cell lung cancer, and gastric, as well as breast cancer.
Now, there are a few Trop-2 targeting ADCs currently on the
market for these indications. However, we believe this new
iADC platform provides a new potential
benefit over those.
ASP2998, or I'll refer to 2998 for
shorthand in this presentation, is a humanized IgG1 against
Trop-2 that carries two distinct payloads.
One is a topoisomerase I inhibitor, your typical cytotoxic
payload. The second is a STING agonist to induce
innate immunity through the STING pathway.
And what we believe is the mechanism of action is illustrated here on the right.
I think I have a pointer here.
So in a four-step process, the ADC
interacts with Trop-2 positive tumor cells, is internalized, and
causes cytotoxicity of those tumor cells through the topoisomerase
I payload.
As the cell is dying, we get immunogenic cell death and
release of a number of different molecules, including the STING agonist.
The STING agonist then is taken up by the surrounding innate immune cells as
well as T cells,
leading to further augmentation of the immune response,
priming of de novo T cell responses, ultimately turning, hopefully,
this tumor from cold to hot and leading to greater
anti-tumor efficacy and hopefully sustained tumor
immunity to give us a longer progression-free survival.
So to jump into the data, first looking in vitro, we
see a substantial benefit of adding a STING agonist to this ADC.
So this is a set of studies using the H292 cells, which are
Trop-2 positive, co-cultured with human PBMCs, and
then increasing amounts of 2998 or either of two
traditional Trop-2
cytotoxic-only ADCs. And what we see on the upper left
there in the cytotoxicity is a substantial shift in potency to the left with
2998 in the presence of these PBMCs.
And in those PBMCs, we see activation of the monocytes,
a hint of activation of the DCs, although they were few in number, and this is
indicative by CD86 upregulation.
We also see CD69 being turned on on both the CD4
and CD8 T cells, as well as the NK cells.
So we see broad immune cell activation in this system.
In addition, and in the same studies, we see release of a number of different
effector molecules, cytokines, and chemokines,
including IL-1 beta and IP-10. They're on the left, which are
canonical downstream of STING agonism, as well as
more distal effector molecules like interferon gamma and TNF.
Now, in this complex PBMC milieu, we do see production of
IL-6.
It is relatively low compared to what we would see with a T cell engager.
And importantly, we do not see IL-6 if we just incubate
PBMCs with 2998 in the absence of a Trop-2.
So this is tumor dependent and relatively low amounts of IL-6.
When we go in vivo and looking at the,
in this case, we're using an MC38
line overexpressing human Trop-2,
setting up these tumor models, and then treating either with vehicle or one of two
doses of 2998. We see in the
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes, an increase in monocytes and their
activation status,
as well as a trend towards more DCs that are more
activated.
We see more NKs, and more of them are expressing granzyme B,
and more of the CD8 T cells are also expressing granzyme B.
So we're seeing turning on of the whole immune system in this
MC38 model.
Now what that means for the animals, so in a very similar set of studies,
in this case, when we inoculated with the MC38 Trop-2,
we waited until they were a fairly large size.
This is 500 cubic millimeters. And then giving a single
treatment of either 2998, shown in two
different dose levels here in the blue, or the traditional
Trop-2 topoisomerase ADCs shown
here. And what we see in this more challenging large MC38 model,
the traditional Trop-2 only ADCs have a very
minimal effect. Whereas at the same dose level
matched here in the dark blue, we see a substantial
control and actual tumor regression.
And even dosing down a little bit, we see tumor stasis.
Now what becomes very interesting is the prolonged immunity.
And this is one of the real value drivers of this platform.
So this is a longer set of experiments to look at, are we
inducing durable immunity with 2998?
So in this case, we took cohorts of mice inoculated with
MC38 Trop-2
and then gave multiple doses of either 2998 or
the control antibody that lacks the STING
agonist but has the cytotoxic payload.
And by giving multiple doses, we could drive complete responses in these animals.
And then we waited for about two or three months and came back and rechallenged
either with MC38
or with Trop-2 or MC38 wild type.
What we observed in the animals that were given 2998
initially cured, they were refractory to
secondary challenge, indicating that they had a robust immune response
to the MC38 Trop-2.
This was 100%... rejection, whereas the
animals that were given only MT38,
sorry, given the ADC without STING agonist, it was
about two-thirds were the control rate with the MT38 Trop-2.
Trop-2 is very immunogenic in mice, so we go to the wild type MT38
that lacks that. We see the same pattern.
The overall control rate is lower.
We do not see any protective immunity with the wild type re-challenge.
So turning from the efficacy and the immunity of these data
to really looking at the stability and then the safety.
As part of our four-week repeat dose GLP tox study performed in
Syngenesic giving once weekly dosing.
After the first week, we see a very traditional
PK profile. Importantly, we're looking here, and there's actually
three lines overlaid here, they're hard to see because they completely overlay, of
the antibody, the antibody with the topoisomerase,
and the antibody with the STING agonist.
And so 2998 in these Syngenesic is remaining
intact. Down here in the bottom, we see a
small blip of both of the payloads free.
This is five orders of magnitude lower.
When we adjust for molecular weight, it's about 1,000-fold lower.
So the vast majority of this molecule is staying intact in these
Syngenesic over this seven-day time period.
Now the toxicology profile of 2998 is very
similar to what you would expect from a Trop-2 ADC only, given the
wide expression of Trop-2 on epithelial cells.
At the lower doses, we saw very slight
hematologic changes, some changes in the pigmentation of the skin.
As we move up into higher doses, doses above where we would get into the clinic,
we identified the cornea, the kidney, the urethra, and
the trachea as potential organs to monitor in the clinical trial.
And ultimately at a high dose, we unfortunately did observe mortality in these
animals, but this is a dose that is much higher than we would ever
treat in people. And importantly, we also
included a cohort here of the individual payloads as
free payloads,
molar matched to a 50 mg per kg level, so a little bit higher than we did here.
And although we got some toxicities that you would expect with a topoisomerase,
with the free STING agonist, we saw very little signs,
and nothing that were clinically significant.
Sporadic changes in the hematology and urinalysis
primarily.
So with that, I'll wrap up and I hope I've introduced 2998
as a potentially first-in-class dual payload immunosuppratory
ADC targeting Trop-2, bringing these two different mechanisms together.
And what the STING agonist is bringing is enhanced efficacy,
enhanced immune activation, and durable tumor immunity.
Taking these data together, we've initiated a first-in-human
clinical trial earlier this year in both the US and Japan.
With that, I'd like to stop and take any questions, but first acknowledge all of
the team out of Stellis as well as Sutro for working together.
And as I said, we've initiated the clinical trial earlier this year, focusing on
safety, tolerability, PK, and PD.
For anyone interested, the QR code does link to the trial.
I have a question.
Because there are differences between types of
cancer in the level of the
Trop-2, and
being that it is homogeneous within the tumors themselves,
in your clinical trial, how are you setting up the threshold?
So for our FIH trial, we are not setting
a threshold. They have to be defined as Trop-2 positive, but we're not setting a
cutoff in the initial trial. This is something we're trying to understand,
not only the level, but also where is the Trop-2 expressed.
Mm-hmm.
Because it's been reported that Trop-2, a lot of it can be intracellular
as well, which obviously would be hidden from the ADCs.
Mm-hmm.
So these are the data we want to collect on the trial. That's a great question.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Go ahead.
A very nice set of data. Nice presentation.
So I was curious, in the mouse models you showed where the two
control Trop-2 ADCs you used with the known TOP1 inhibitor
payloads had minimal efficacy compared to vehicle.
Do you have a sense of what the contribution is of your two payloads in
vivo in mice?
Yep. That's a great question. Thank you.
And so we have done studies using the single
controls. In those efficacy studies,
the primary driver, and I'm not going to put a number on it,
early is the topoisomerase. As you go
later in that study, the STING agonism really kicks in and brings
that real dip down in maintenance.
So it's a combination of the two. Didn't have time to share those data. Thank you.
Yeah, really nice presentation. I was just curious, with the PK data you were
talking about, especially in Syngeneic but also in your activity models,
were you monitoring for ADA? Did you see a high incidence of that?
And then how, upon repeat dosing, did it impact both
the unconjugated drug exposures as well as the ADC?
Yeah. It's a great question. So we did see some ADA
upon re-exposure, especially after the third and fourth
dose.
The overall impact of the PK was pretty minimal.
So we measured PK at the first dose and after the fourth dose.
It was actually quite similar. So at least in these studies, the ADAs formed
but were not significantly impactful.
Thank you.
All right. Oh, is that another question?
No. Okay. Sorry. Thank you so, so much. This is fascinating.
Thank you so much.
Right. Last but not least, and ready with a new version,
is Daniela Garcia from the University of San Antonio,
Texas. And she's going to be talking about targeting
EYA4 to disrupt the genome stability in
triple-negative breast cancer.
Hello, everyone. My name is Daniela Garcia.
I'm a post-baccalaureate research fellow with the American Cancer
Society at the UT San Antonio campus, and these are the correct
slides.
So these are my disclosures.
So our protein of interest is eyes absent homolog 4, or EYA4,
which belongs to the EYA family of atypical dual
phosphatases. They have a conserved C-terminal EYA
domain with tyrosine phosphatase activity and an N-terminal region
with serine/threonine phosphatase activity, as well as transcriptional coactivation
functions. In comparison to kinases that are well-studied and
targeted, which add phosphate groups to the residues of serine, threonine, and
tyrosine
for regulating protein activity, phosphatases remove the phosphate groups and are
just as critical for signaling pathways, but remain comparatively
unexplored. So for example, upon DNA damage,
ATR/ATM phosphorylate targets such as gamma H2AX
and EYA4, and phosphorylated EYA4 can dephosphorylate gamma
H2AX and RAD51, promoting repair through homologous recombination.
But when EYA4 is lost or depleted, cells become homologous
recombination deficient or HRD positive, and this results in cell
death. So triple-negative breast cancer is an aggressive
subtype of breast cancer with limited targeted therapies due to the lack of
estrogen receptor, progesterone receptor, and HER2
expression. And TNBC patients are more likely to
carry the BRCA1 or 2 mutations, with a prevalence of about 10% to
20%, representing a clinically significant
subset of patients who are HRD positive.
If we look broadly at genetic predispositions, BRCA1 or
2 account for a substantial fraction of these inherited mutations.
However, many tumors fall into the other mutations category,
highlighting this genetic heterogeneity of breast cancer.
And functionally, when genes such as BRCA1 or 2 are mutated,
cells lose their ability to repair double-strand breaks, which creates a
therapeutic vulnerability,
leading to therapies that can not only exploit preexisting HR deficiency,
but also attempt to actively induce it.
Potentially sensitizing
HR-proficient tumors to platinum-based chemotherapies or, for
example, the use of PARP inhibitors, and expand the population of
TNBC patients who could possibly benefit from these types of
treatments. So first we asked whether EYA4 is
epigenetically altered in TNBC, and with
methylation sequence analysis, and we
did around 30 patient samples, showing that EYA4 is hypermethylated
at the first intron-exon junction in TNBC compared to the
matched normal tissue. And then while DNA methylation is
classically associated with gene silencing, its effects are highly
context dependent. Prior studies and observations suggest that
EYA4 hypermethylation in this region may be
associated with increased expression rather than repression.
So we did analysis of a breast invasive carcinoma data set
showing that EYA4 alterations occur in approximately
2.8% of patients driven by mRNA upregulation.
And then we then validated this by assessing EYA4 expression across
breast cancer cell lines using QR-PCR and immunobloting,
and we see that the TNBC cell line,
MDAMB-231,
exhibits the highest endogenous EYA4 expression at both the transcript and
the protein level. So now that we know that EYA4 is
overexpressed in breast cancer, we asked whether it can contribute to something
like tumor progression and whether it could be a viable therapeutic target.
To address this, we used two in vivo models
with luciferase-labeled cancer cells,
where tumor burden can be monitored with
bioluminescent signaling.
In this system, light emission correlates with the number of the viable tumor
cells. So in the top panel, EYA4 was overexpressed in MCF7
cells,
which were injected orthotopically into the mammary fat pad.
And this represents a primary tumor xenograft model.
Here, EYA4 expression leads to a significant increase in the
bioluminescent signal over time, indicating tumor growth.
And visibly, these tumors are larger in volume, confirming that EYA4
promotes the primary tumor growth in vivo.
And then in this bottom panel, we used a tail vein metastasis model with
TNBC cells where EYA4 was depleted using
shRNA. And loss of EYA4 results in the reduction in the
bioluminescent signaling. Through histological analysis of the lung
tissue, we confirmed a reduction in metastatic lesions as well as
the foci. And thus, we can
see that EYA4 is not only sufficient to drive tumor growth, but
also it is required for metastasis.
We next explored how EYA4 functions at the molecular level,
specifically in maintaining genomic stability under replication stress.
To assess the DNA damage, we
measured with the gamma H2AX. It's a well-established marker for DNA
damage, double-strand breaks. H2AX is a variant of the histone H2A
protein, and upon DNA damage, it becomes phosphorylated at the serine
139 residue to form gamma H2AX. And it then
accumulates at the sites of DNA damage at these discrete nuclear foci,
which can be visualized using the immunofluorescent staining.
And then in EYF4-depleted cells, we see an increase in gamma H2AX
foci, shown here in red.
The accumulation of these foci indicates unresolved DNA damage rather than
efficient repair.Given that the loss of EYF4 leads to
this increase in DNA damage, we next asked how EYF4 functions at the
site of
damaged DNA. So to test this, we wanted to see whether
EYF4 directly binds DNA. We've
used microscale thermophoresis or MST to quantify
binding interactions and measure affinity.
We found that EYF4 binds single-strand DNA with affinity in the nanomolar
range. And when we introduce a phosphomimetic mutation,
we see that the DNA binding is significantly reduced.
In the SQ/TQ motif, this is a consensus site for ATR/ATM
phosphorylation. And then looking at their protein structure in the N-terminal
region of EYF4, we see that there are features such as a basic tail
in that span of amino acids and also an AT-hook-like
motif, which are known to support DNA binding.
So currently, we're mapping this region further to see how these
are interacting with DNA. And we also performed
histone direct pull-down, followed by mass spec to identify
interactions with these chromatin-associated proteins, such as
H2AX. Normally, EYF4 would associate with chromatin, and then upon
DNA damage, becomes phosphorylated and then
it detaches, which reduces its DNA binding and releases it from chromatin, and then
EYF4 can then act on its downstream targets
or substrates. And then having shown that EYF4 is binding to
DNA and functions at the sites of DNA damage, we next asked whether its phosphatase
activity is also regulated in this context.
And so to do that, we
measured using a malachite green assay to quantify the release of free phosphate
as a readout of the phosphatase activity.
And we found that EYF4 exhibits phosphatase activity at the tyrosine 142
residue with minimal activity towards serine 139.
And then also in the presence of DNA, its activity is
significantly enhanced. And so this suggests that DNA
binding is not only localizing EYF4 to sites of damage, but it's
also directly stimulating its enzymatic activity.
And because this is a defined and measurable catalytic activity, it highlights
EYF4 as a potentially drugable target.
So we then investigated further whether EYF4 can be therapeutically targeted.
To assess HR, we looked at RAD51 phosphorylation with
immunofluorescence, and phosphorylated
RAD51 foci, shown in red, serves as a marker of HR
disruption. So upon depletion of EYF4, we observed a strong increase of
RAD51 foci indicating impaired function, disrupted HR.
And we identified a small molecule inhibitor, CIDd ending
in 89, as a top candidate from a drug screening.
And looking at this growth curve, treatment with this inhibitor most efficiently
suppresses growth compared to the control of the other candidates.
There's a reduction in cell viability measured
by
an
MTT assay, which is quantifying metabolic activity as a proxy
for viable cells, and then further showing this in a
dose-dependent curve with increasing concentrations of the inhibitor reducing
EYF4 activity. And then to directly measure HR, we use the
dRGFP system, the gene conversion assay, where a double-strand
break is induced, and then restoring by HR restores
GFP expression. So treatment with this inhibitor leads to a
dose-dependent decrease in GFP,
and a decrease in GFP positive cells indicating
reduced HR efficiency.
And so in conclusion, our data identifies EYF4 as promoting
a key regulator of HR and genome stability in TNBC and
supporting DNA repair, while its loss or inhibition
induces HR deficiency, DNA damage
accumulation, and reduced tumor cell survival, as well as
the pharmacological inhibition of phenocopies, a type of
genetic depletion, highlighting EYF4 as a potential target, and
potentially sensitizing TNBC to other
DNA-damaging therapeutic targeted therapies.
And lastly, I would like to acknowledge my mentors, Dr.
Eloise Dreher, lab members, and then not mentioned, but also
for my slides, Dmitry Kovalsky, Daruka Mohadevan, Stanley McCarvey,
Dong Xiao, the American Cancer Society, and my program directors, as well as
clinical mentor, Dr. Gail Tomlinson. Thank you.
Okay, I'll start.
So
we know that for PARP inhibitors,
BRCAness-
Yes
... it's really a good way to know which patients might
benefit from it.
Mm-hmm.
What you're showing us is that you can potentially sensitize-
Yes
... regardless of BRCAness.
Mm-hmm.
So
are you envisioning
this as a sensitization, so it will be open for all, or
are you envisioning this maybe as a translational
potential for overcoming resistance?
Yeah. I think that's something really important.
You're talking about PARP inhibitors, which upon DNA
damage, and you see for single-strand breaks, if PARP is inhibited, it's not
able to perform, or PARP1 is not able to perform its function in base
excision repair, and then in cells that are
HR deficient, that's the key that because you're inhibiting that, then
those cells ultimately to death. And I think maybe targeting something like
EYF4 to kind of induce a homologous recombination deficient state
in combination therapy, and then further exploiting this vulnerability
is a really interesting application and type of therapy that is
definitely worth exploring.
So yeah, I think that's really interesting.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
I think so too.
The phosphorylation,
the efficacy test.
Mm-hmm.
How easy or difficult would be to do that in patient samples?
Yeah, that's really interesting.
I know right now everything has been using with inhibitor
has been in vivo.
But as far as application to patient samples, I'm
not too sure. I'm sure that's definitely future directions, and with use of the
inhibitor, that's later stages. But yeah, very interesting
question.
That's very exciting.
Anybody else?
All right. I think that we're going to conclude the session.
This was fantastic. Let's just acknowledge everybody again.
Thank you so much.